voy a dividir 3.771 entre 8 haremos una
división larga y lo primero que queremos
hacer es pensar pensar en si 8 caben 3
pero no verdad no caben 3 8 es un número
mucho más grande que el 3 así que
seguimos 8 caben 37 pues si en efecto 8
por 4 es igual a 32 8 por 5 es igual a
40 aunque 40 ya es muy grande entonces 8
caben 37 4 veces 4 por 8 es igual a 32
restamos y obtenemos un residuo de 5 ajá
entonces aquí va 5 y lo que está pasando
en el fondo es ver cuántas veces cabe el
8 en 3.700 y decimos que cabe 400 veces
por eso yo estoy poniendo el 4 en el
lugar de las centésimas
entonces 400 por 8 es igual a 3200
cuando restamos 3200 de 3.700 nos queda
500 pero sigamos con la división
tradicional cuando decimos que 8 caben
37 4 veces lo que en realidad estamos
diciendo es que 8 caben
1700 400 veces entonces aquí tenemos
aquí tenemos un 5 el cual está en el
lugar de las centésimas ajá entonces es
un 500 son 500 ahora bajamos el 7
bajamos este 7 cuántas veces cabe 8 en
50 y 78 caben 57 veamos cuántas veces 8
por 4 es igual a 32 8 por 5 48 por 6 48
8 por 7 54 entonces aquí va un 7 ajá
acaba un 7 7 por 8 es igual a 56 dije 54
antes me equivoqué lo siento y no me sé
bien la tabla del 7 a lo que parece 7
por 8 es igual a 56 aquí va a un 7
entonces luego multiplicamos 7 por 8 es
igual a 56 hacemos una resta 57 menos 56
esto es igual a 1 esto es igual a 1
después después bajamos este 1 este uno
va
para abajo así lo bajamos y cuántas
veces cabe el 8 en el 11 sólo una vez
luego uno por ocho es igual a 8 restamos
otra vez y nos queda un residuo 11 menos
8 es igual a 3 3 es el residuo por lo
tanto 8 caben 3.771 471 veces y nos
queda un residuo de 3 terminamos